des roses blanches sous le nom des 14
femmes assassinées le 6 décembre 1989 un
tireur fou sèment la terreur à
polytechnique il abat 14 jeunes
étudiantes un attentat anti féministe
qui dit a tenu à souligner de savoir que
des femmes ont été stoppés dans leur
étude parce qu'elles étaient des femmes
c'est quelque chose qui vient me
chercher très personnellement c'est très
significatif pour il dit elle est
récipiendaire de la bourse de la rose
blanche une récompense remise aux
étudiantes en génie l'idée un peu ceux
ci que on incarne c'est cité étudiante
le qui ont pas pu pousser ou leur réseau
titre tchèque chaque année j'ai importé
des roses
sur la plage du 6 décembre les gens se
sont réunis pour écouter la cérémonie
diffusée sur internet à cause du mauvais
temps le 16 décembre c'est toujours
imprégnée de
beaucoup de
tristesse à 17h10
geneviève sonia mots de barbara le nom
des femmes assassinées a résonné à
montréal une rose déposée pour chaque
vie perdue une lumière pour chacune un
événement qui selon refaire chaque année
avec ses magnifiques faisceau de lumière
pour penser à elle
pensez aux familles mais également avoir
une réflexion en tant que société sûre
qu'est ce qui doit être fait pour
empêcher la violence faite aux filles et
aux femmes et bien sûr les féminicides
on a vraiment un devoir de mémoire c'est
paul le québec qu'on aime c'est pas dans
nos valeurs on a vu
malheureusement encore la violence
contre les femmes avait sa main donc
pour continuer de se battre ailleurs au
pays des universités comme celle de
moncton ont souligné la tragédie j'ai
envie qu'il était prêt à se lever à la
chambre des communes des députés
canadiens se sont recueillis en silence
en souvenir des victimes des
commémorations qui se déroule sur fond
de féminicide au québec au bout de
dix-huit féministes et de cette année on
sent qu'il ya un besoin de plus de
discussions de plus de ressources de
plus d'actions à la fois se rappeler
jamais oublier les victimes de cet
attentat féministe est à la fois mais
agir pour les victimes de donner des
victimes qui pourraient mourir sous les
balles les armes à feu y prolifèrent
dans certains quartiers de montréal ça
fait 32 heures cette fois ce qui me
frappe c'est ramallah sur l'absurdité
que les gens comme nous les survivants
les familles continuent doivent
continuer à se battre pour un meilleur
contrôle des armes alors que la grande
majorité que tu as far as et alors que
on est élu sur
le projet de loi c 21 est trop laxiste
selon polly se souvient le rachat des
armes d'assaut interdite et volontaires
les armes de poing toujours légal à
moins d'une législation municipale
l'attentât du 6 décembre 89 a été
qualifiée d' antiféministe un mouvement
qui est toujours en force et qui trouve
écho sur les médias sociaux le web en
fait c'est un peu comme une loupe et
effectivement c'est un espace où l'on
peut se retrouver partager un même
discours donc ça donne une impression de
force de grandeur l'antiféminisme ne
serait donc pas plus présent mais sa
présence inquiète prendre au sérieux les
féministes qui dénoncent l'entv mener et
là j'aimerais faire une parenthèse c'est
nul besoin de s'identifier soi même
comme féministe pour être la cible de
propos d' attaques de menaces de viol
notamment
antiféministe de répertorier et d'alerté
également quand ça se produit parce que
si on est visée nous comme féministe se
pourrait que d'autres femmes le soir
pour que plus jamais ne s'éteigne la
lumière dans les yeux des femmes parce
qu'elles sont femmes ici marie josée
paquet comme radio canada montréal